yo no sé a ustedes pero a mí los
problemas de torque solían causarle
mucha ansiedad y creo que eso era porque
realmente yo no comprendía que era el
torque y cómo encontrarlo así que lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es mostrarles
cómo encontrar el torque hay formas
conceptuales y trucos que nos van a
ayudar y quiero compartirlo con ustedes
para que de ahora en adelante ninguno de
nosotros tenga ansiedad al resolver
algún problema de torque específicamente
los problemas de torque que me daban más
ansiedad era donde la fuerza llegaba con
un ángulo extraño vamos a resolver esto
vamos a encontrar el torque de esta
fuerza de 10 newtons ejercida con un
ángulo de 30 grados y la primera cosa
que tenemos que hacer cuando resolvemos
un problema de torque es encontrar el
eje el eje es el punto en el cual el
objeto va a rotar así que digamos que
nos dicen que en este problema el eje se
encuentra en el centro de esta barra así
que el centro del objeto va a ser el eje
a lo mejor esto es una tabla que tiene
un clavo en el medio cuál
ahora es una vista desde arriba de esas
puertas que rotan cuando uno entra a un
restaurante u hotel elegante así que el
eje se encuentra en el centro y esto es
crucial ya que si una fuerza va a
ejercer un torque esto tiene que
aplicarse en algún lugar alrededor del
eje en otras palabras si queremos abrir
esta puerta giratoria empujándola o
aplicando una fuerza justo en su centro
no va a pasar nada porque no va a rotar
pero mientras más lejos del eje
apliquemos la fuerza obtendremos un
torque más grande así que una fuerza
aplicada aquí va a aplicar mucho mayor
torque que una fuerza aplicada aquí y es
por eso que las manijas de la puerta
siempre están a un extremo ya que sería
bastante difícil abrir una puerta si
tiene la manija cerca del eje y si no lo
han intentado traten de hacerlo es
bastante difícil abrir una puerta así y
ahora que ya identificamos el eje
podemos encontrar la cantidad de torque
ejercido y lo primero que yo podría
hacer para encontrar el torque
es decir bueno yo conozco la fórmula del
torque y el torque es igual a efe por d
o en este caso efe por r pero aquí lo
importante es es saber que está r
representa al vector que apunta desde el
eje hasta el punto en donde se aplica la
fuerza en este caso va desde el eje
hacia el punto en donde se aplica la
fuerza que es aquí ésta es nuestra r
vean que r no es el radio completo y
tampoco es la longitud de todo el objeto
siempre se mide desde el eje hacia el
punto en donde se aplica la fuerza y
técnicamente está r es un vector podemos
considerarlo como un vector de posición
y siempre apunta desde el eje hacia
donde se aplica la fuerza y no en
sentido contrario la dirección nunca es
así el eje siempre es alejándose del eje
desde él
hasta el punto en donde se aplica la
fuerza en el objeto vamos a darle una
cantidad y digamos que es de 2 metros y
ahora podríamos calcular el torque pero
tienen que ser cuidadosos un error que
yo hubiera cometido es decir ah bueno
esta efe pues son estos 10 newtons la
razón a estos 2 metros por lo que mi
torque va a ser de 20 cierto 2 por 10
pero no esto no es así ya que está efe
no me está representando necesariamente
la fuerza total si escribimos así esta
fórmula para el torque nos referimos a
que ésta f es aquella parte de la fuerza
que es perpendicular a r así que sólo el
componente perpendicular de esta fuerza
es lo que usaríamos en esta fórmula ya
que es la única que va a ejercer un
torque en este objeto el componente que
es paralelo a r no va a ejercer porque
alguno y esto tiene sentido si el vector
de 10 newtons lo descompongo en dos
vectores de esta manera a éste le llamo
efe paralelo ya que esta fuerza es
paralela
va en la misma dirección en la que va
ere y también tengo este componente
perpendicular que le llamo eje
perpendicular ya que este componente es
perpendicular al vector r solamente este
componente perpendicular es el que va a
ejercer torque lo que tiene sentido ya
que el torque es una fuerza que va a
ocasionar que algo comience a rotar o
que cambie su rotación así que el único
componente de esta fuerza de 10 newtons
que va a hacer que este objeto comience
a rotar es el componente perpendicular
es así como empujamos una puerta para
que comience a rotar no jalamos el eje
así si yo tratara de abrir estas puertas
rotatorias empujando las así pues
pensarían que estoy loca ya que esto no
va a hacer que la puerta rota y de la
misma manera si yo trato de jalar la
puerta así pues tampoco voy a hacer que
la puerta a rote necesitamos ejercer una
fuerza perpendicular a este vector r
sólo así podemos hacer que esta puerta
rote así que solo el componente
perpendicular de una fuerza es decir que
es perpendicular a r es el que me va a
ejercer el torque solo este componente y
lo podemos encontrar si aquí tenemos 30
grados aquí tenemos un ángulo interno
alterno por lo que también será de 30
grados
estos ángulos son iguales como vimos en
geometría por lo que este componente
perpendicular veamos está opuesto al
ángulo de 30 grados por lo que puedo
decir que esto va a ser igual a 10
newtons por el seno de 30 grados y 10
newtons por el seno de 30 grados va a
ser igual a 5 newtons así que finalmente
puedo decir que el torque ejercido por
el componente perpendicular de esta
fuerza es de 5 newtons x que tan lejos
se aplicó esa fuerza del eje r es 2
metros y nos queda que el torque es de
10 newtons por metro
en este caso no me extrañaría que me
dijeran justo por esto por lo que los
problemas de torque me causan ansiedad
tengo que acordarme que estos dos metros
vienen del eje hasta donde se aplicó la
fuerza también tengo que acordarme que
solo el componente perpendicular de la
fuerza que llega con un ángulo es el que
tengo que usar en la fórmula y además
tengo que recordar que lo de
perpendicular se refiere a que sea
perpendicular a este vector r y quizás
se pregunten si es que hay una manera
más sencilla de resolver esto y si si la
hay ya que este componente de la fuerza
siempre va a ser el componente
perpendicular a r podemos tomarlo en
cuenta cuando escribimos la fórmula en
otras palabras la manera en la que
encontramos este componente
perpendicular es tomar la magnitud de la
fuerza total en este caso de 10 newtons
y lo multiplicamos por el seno del
ángulo entre el vector r y el vector
fuerza que es lo que hicimos para
encontrar estos 5 newtons así que por
qué no escribimos esta fórmula
explícitamente
en términos de la fuerza total
multiplicado por el seno de teta que
será el componente perpendicular y luego
lo multiplicamos por r y esto df por
seno de teta representa el componente
perpendicular de la fuerza y luego lo
multiplicamos por r como lo hicimos aquí
ahora en la mayoría de los libros de
texto esta fórmula la escriben así les
gusta dejar el seno de theta al final se
ve un poco más limpio así que tenemos
efe por ere por seno de teta y ahora si
podemos poner directamente la fuerza
completa de los 10 newtons en esta
fórmula
seguimos incluyendo los dos metros de r
y esta teta base del ángulo entre el
vector r y el vector fuerza y esto es
crucial si ustedes van a estar usando
esta fórmula en lugar de esta otra
fórmula tienen que recordar que este
ángulo de acá siempre es el ángulo entre
r y eje vector fuerza y mi vector r que
es el que va a partir del eje hasta el
punto en donde se aplica la fuerza y el
an
en este caso fue de 30 grados y en
algunas ocasiones no es tan obvio como
es que pueden ustedes encontrar este
ángulo lo primero que hay que hacer es
identificar la dirección de efe y la
dirección de r y la forma más segura de
encontrar esto es mover o imaginarnos
que movemos el vector fuerza y hacemos
que coincida el inicio del vector con el
inicio del vector r y después encontrar
cuál es el ángulo que forman estos dos
vectores nuevamente los ángulos internos
alternos son iguales por lo que aquí
tendremos 30 grados y ese es el ángulo
el ángulo entre el vector
efe y el vector r ese es el ángulo que
nos interesa cuando usamos esta fórmula
vamos a copiar esta fórmula para usarla
en otro ejemplo ya que la única forma de
ser bueno en esto y que no nos causa
ansiedad es practicar tomamos nuestra
nueva fórmula porque es igual a efe por
r por el seno de theta y digamos que
estamos aplicando una fuerza aquí e
imaginen que nos están dando estas
distancias
saber cuál doctor que va a ser ejercido
por esta fuerza de 20 minutos aplicada
aquí usamos esta fórmula me efe va a ser
todo mi vector fuerza mis 20 newtons
aquí ya no tenemos que descomponer el
vector efe en sus componentes así que
ponemos la magnitud completa de esta
fuerza que es de 20 newtons multiplicada
por r y cuál es r pues aquí tenemos tres
distancias diferentes cuál vamos a usar
recuerden que r se define como el vector
que va desde el eje hasta donde se
aplica la fuerza aquí mi eje sigue
estando en el medio y mi fuerza se está
aplicando aquí así que mi r va a ser de
un metro no va a ser la de tres metros
ni la de cuatro metros si les dan varios
números tienen que tener cuidado y
elegir aquel vector que va a partir del
eje de rotación hasta el punto en donde
se aplica la fuerza esa es la magnitud
de este vector un metro y lo
multiplicamos por el seno del ángulo que
se forma entre el vector r
vector fuerza pensemos en ello la fuerza
va en esta dirección
abajo a la derecha rebase a la izquierda
el verdadero ángulo entre r
efe lo vamos a encontrar cuando
coloquemos el inicio del vector efe con
el inicio del vector r imaginamos que
hacemos esto y ahora sí se apunta abajo
a la derecha r apunta hacia la izquierda
y el ángulo entre ellos va a ser este
ángulo y hay varias maneras en las que
podemos encontrar este ángulo podemos
imaginar dibujar un triángulo rectángulo
aquí si estos son 60 grados y aquí
tenemos 90 grados pues el ángulo de acá
será de 30 grados ya que los ángulos
internos de un triángulo siempre nos van
a dar 180 grados si los sumamos si esto
es 30 y esto es 90 pues este ángulo será
de 120 así que escribimos 120 grados
aquí este es el ángulo real entre el
vector fuerza y el vector r es el ángulo
de 120 grados porque 90 más 30 es igual
a 120
así que el ángulo entre r efe es todo
esto de aquí que son 120 grados es el
ángulo entre r y f pero quizás a ustedes
les preocupe que esto fue bastante
trabajo y digan yo no quiero hacer eso
quiero tomar mi vector f tal cual y
determinar el ángulo / efe jr de verdad
tengo que imaginar que muevo este vector
pues no no es así y no es tan difícil
técnicamente para medir el ángulo
tendríamos que colocar estos vectores de
manera que sus inicios coincidan pero si
los colocamos de manera que ambos puntos
finales se conecten también obtendremos
el ángulo entre estos vectores bien este
ángulo de aquí yo sé que esto es 60
grados y sé que hay 180 grados aquí por
lo que 180 menos 60 me da 120 grados y
esta es otra manera de encontrar el
ángulo que vamos a colocar aquí en esta
fórmula así que no tenemos que imaginar
que movemos a este vector y lo colocamos
inició con inicio con este otro
si los vectores están uniendo sus
cabezas o las partes en donde terminen
los vectores si encontramos el ángulo
entre estos dos vectores de esta forma
también nos sirve para usarlo en la
fórmula que en este caso es 120 grados y
quizás digan bueno qué pasa si aquí me
equivoco qué pasa si en lugar de poner
esos 120 grados
pongo directamente los 60 grados que veo
aquí que va a suceder pues resulta que
obtendremos de nuevo la respuesta
correcta la fórmula de torque es
bastante amigable en este sentido ya que
aunque aquí yo hubiera usado 60 el seno
de 60 grados es el mismo que el seno de
120 grados y no es coincidencia esto es
porque este ángulo de aquí de 120 grados
/ efe jr es ángulo suplementario a éste
de 60 grados ya que noten que todo el
ángulo que va desde aquí hasta acá es de
180 grados si esto es 120 este 60 va a
ser el ángulo suplementario a este otro
ya que
ambos tienen que sumar 180 grados y el
seno de ángulos suplementarios siempre
nos da la misma respuesta así que si
aquí pongo 60 grados mi fórmula va a
funcionar de todas maneras así que
aunque definimos el ángulo entre
vectores como el ángulo que se forma
entre ellos cuando los unimos en su
inicio podemos hacer que coincidan en
donde terminan ambos y obtendremos
también este ángulo y como estamos
encontrando el seno de ese ángulo
podemos usar cualquiera de estos dos
ángulos pues son ángulos suplementarios
cuyo seno nos va a dar la misma
respuesta así que pegamos nuestro vector
eje con nuestro vector r encontramos
cualquiera de estos dos ángulos y
podemos usarlo en esta fórmula de torque
y así obtendremos la respuesta correcta
en resumen podemos encontrar el torque
el componente perpendicular de la fuerza
y lo multiplicamos por el vector r el
vector r es aquel que inicia en donde se
encuentra el eje y termina en el lugar
en donde se está aplicando la fuerza y
lo de perpendicular se refiere a que es
el componente perpendicular al vector r
o podemos usar esta fórmula en donde
usamos nuestra fuerza completa f es la
magnitud completa de la fuerza es re
sigue siendo la magnitud del vector r y
theta representa el ángulo que se forma
entre el vector r y el vector f cuando
se encuentran unidos extremo con extremo
cuando está en inicio con inicio y como
el seno de ángulos suplementarios es
igual también podemos usar el ángulo
suplementario de este ángulo / efe jr